[Applause]
all right now at this point uh it
doesn't matter how much progress you've
made jotting things down if you've got
nothing written down you're like i
literally just got my pens out can i ask
you all to just put all pins and things
out of your hands and i just want to
talk through don't worry about plenty of
time this is going to be on the screen
or lesson i just want to talk through
what are we doing what is it how does it
relate to what we've done already and uh
why is it important okay
so this heading the key word that i want
you to focus on is this one right here
applications what does it mean
in maths when we talk about how you
apply something it's like hey you
learned a skill you know how to do a
thing now
but what can you do with that skill what
kinds of problems or what kinds of
scenarios can you apply that skill to
now you'll often see textbooks kind of
divide up you know the development of
skill with the application of this but
this is why we're spending a whole
lesson on it's not because the textbook
does that
it's because and i actually invite you
to do this uh
after we finish this we're trying to
take about 15 minutes okay i invite you
to go and look up and i'll even write
this to give us all a prompt to do it
go and get last year's
paper
uh last year's hsc exam paper for your
course right and one of the things which
i'm going to highlight when we go in
there is that there used to be lots of
questions that were what i like to call
it sounds a bit weird but they were
called naked questions it's like here's
a log function differentiate it that's
it i'm not going to ask you to do
anything else like one mark two marks
full stop okay they didn't care whether
you could use that skill to actually
progress or make any more sophisticated
thought right now the thing which and i
don't know if anyone's got like older
siblings or friends who are a bit older
the thing that struck people last year
when they opened the paper
was there was a much smaller number of
those just here's an easy one or two
marks right some of the papers or some
of the questions rather
welcome michael you'd open up the paper
and there'd be two full pages facing you
and it was just one question
a bit like this
see how this is like what is this three
three parts right actually it's not
really three parts it's kind of like
four or five they just haven't given you
that many letters the multi-part
questions even in the past
these are the kinds of things with the
htc is actually trying to see can you do
this i don't want you just to be able to
apply a formula i want you to see if you
can interpret that
progress with that solve a bigger
problem with it okay
so
pick up your pins again and now let's
start to work through these together now
that you understand why this is so
important that we cannot just do a skill
but apply that skill to a problem
it first starts by saying
show that the tangent this is part a
to y equals log base e of x
you can write that either in the way
they've shown or
if you're slightly lazy like i am lnx is
also acceptable i just want to really
emphasize the same thing different
notation
show that the tangent to this
at this particular point they name a
point t and it's got these coordinates e
comma one
[Applause]
show that that tangent has this
particular equation okay now first thing
to note right what is the operative
word here what's the verb what's the
thing they're asking you to do
show that okay so there are zero points
for actually getting this result they're
like we know what the result is i want
you to prove it and we've talked about
this before in such a case that you
actually can't prove it you could still
use that result for subsequent parts all
right
now i've jotted down some important
information we want to get to the
equation of a tangent
[Applause]
okay now you've been supplied the point
through which the tangent passes we need
one other piece of information to get
the equation of the tangent anyone want
to give me a suggestion
here go ahead
we need a gradient right
point gradient form that'll do it for us
do you see what i mean by this is an
application of the problem nowhere do
they say would you please differentiate
this thing for me you kind of just have
to work out that that's what's required
okay
but you've just told me i need a
gradient so i'm going to say d y
on dx equals
and now we're going to differentiate now
this is just your stock standard log x
do you remember from last lesson and
that was two days ago what's our
derivative
1 over x
okay now i told you guys before um i
think it's important to not just have
equations but to actually glue all of
your equations with the right words and
the right symbols so that you know what
they mean okay so rather than just
saying like a lot of people please do
not write this
on their next line they're just going to
do this
imagine you're me
you're the marker and you see a student
do this right what do you think they're
doing why have they done this because
it's not like wrong
there's a reason that they did it can
anyone tell me where they've gotten this
wrong
have a look it's all there on the board
or in the question
yeah fantastic but this is exactly what
they were supposed to do and what we're
supposed to do there's the x coordinate
e
they've just substituted it in okay
here's my problem
what does this mean d y on dx
like literally what does it mean yeah
michael um
thank you the derivative of y
with respect to x as x changes y will
also change and this is how that happens
okay now what the next line suggests is
that this is always how it's changing d
y and dx just equals that but it's not
always that you put a different value of
x like x equals 2 or 5 or negative 1 and
you'll get a different value of this
so this is actually something separate
to that so instead of writing just that
here's i'm going to suggest that you do
right
we took the x value from here so i'm
going to say
therefore
at
t
so now i'm stating why i'm about to
substitute it in and further instead of
calling it just dy on dx
i'm just going to look forward across
the question now this is a bit sneaky
because i've already done this question
so i know this in advance but this is a
skill i want you to practice
you can see in part a we're getting this
uh gradient of a tangent that's what i'm
about to calculate it's not the only
gradient i'm about to work out though
can you have a look at the question go
ahead and tell me what's the other
gradient i'm gonna have to work out in a
minute yeah keegan
yeah the gradient of the normal now some
of you remember what the normal is
others of you i'm going to remind you in
a second but i'm going to have two
different gradients flying around it's a
recipe of a disaster when you're like
i'm just writing gradient and i'm like
which one is which so here's what i'm
going to do instead
what is our normal pronumeral for
gradient
m so i'll say m but i want to specify
what m it is so i use a little
subscript
just written underneath there the
gradient of the tangent is going to be
and now i'm ready to do my substitution
1 over e
same answer but this notation makes a
huge amount of difference to what you're
communicating okay
i've got a gradient why'd i do that
again
why did i get a gradient for
to find the equation yeah i'm looking
for an equation i'll put it together
with this point there's a gradient i
don't think you need my help for this
part okay
your equation of the tangent put them in
and then can you get me to this result
it should tell you two or three lines of
working can you go ahead and do that
i'll give you 10 seconds head start and
then i'll do mine on the board
okay
so i promised you that 10 second head
start here is me trying to do my catch
up okay now remember as we as you guys
reminded me
the operative verb here is show that so
i really want to make sure i don't miss
any don't skip any lines of working here
that's why you might think mr ooh i did
that faster than you did i'm like yeah i
can do it faster but the burden of
communication is on me to actually show
you i know what i'm doing okay that's
why i quoted the point gradient forms so
you can see i've done this really
clearly i haven't skipped any kind of
expansion or simplification i've got
everything that you can see proves i
know that they're right does that make
sense
okay so far and that's part a sounds too
complicated okay
now part b says it's like the next step
find the equation of the normal now this
point even though part c is the one that
asks us to draw i'm going to ask all of
us to do this sort of now right part c
says like sketch and that's what's going
to help us understand the difference
between the tangent
and the normal so can we all get and
this time put a bit of effort into it
we've done some really rough sketches
but this time we're going to use the
sketch to help us answer the question so
let's draw the best neatest sketch that
we can
get use a ruler for your set of axes and
all that i'm going to do the same
and let's try and draw what this is
going to look like so we can see where
the tangent goes and how that relates to
the normal so here's how i suggest you
start
i chose the wrong red mark
all my markers suck okay
[Applause]
okay
now i haven't put much on here because
at this point i actually want you to see
the way in which i think through this to
make this accurate okay i drew my set of
axes that's the easy part here's my y
equals log x curve and now i'm slowly
going to put on the stuff that i've
already known so that i can add on to it
okay
now
this point t where is it this is the
point at which i remind you that this
number e
is equal to roughly 2.7
right roughly 2.7 now i don't have to
get this exact but it's going to help me
if my diagram is like accurate enough to
work from right so have a look at this
diagram and where roughly should x
equals 2.7
be where does it belong
now to get a handle on this my
suggestion is that you remember what
that value is right there what is the x
intercept
of this log x
curve
any suggestions
hmm
can i give you a clue
you guys remember we've been um josh
we'll see if your answer is right in a
second once i give everyone the clue
remember we've been comparing
exponentials and logs a lot right this
log curve is just the exponential curve
but it's been reflected okay
do you guys remember you don't have to
tell me but do you remember what the y
intercept up there is it's generally an
easier number for people to remember
it's the same y-intercept as this
x-intercept josh do you want to tell us
what it is
that's okay well let's see who remembers
what this y intercept is over here
it's it's 1 right because if this is
like say 2 to the power of x 2 to the
power of zero
is one uh three to the power of zero is
one whatever to the power of zero is one
so this one is the same thing but for x
instead of y
now if that's one now you can see where
2.7 should be right at least roughly
i can even eyeball this i don't have a
ruler but that's going to be 2.
3 looks like it's going to be here so
i'm going to draw a line roughly where i
think 2.7 should be that looks about
right to me
how do you feel about that
ish okay so that point right there
that's going to be
t
okay
now i actually i've been a bit sneaky i
have not probably drawn enough of this
you'll see why in a second
but i can at least put onto here and
your ruler is gonna be so helpful i can
at least put on to here the equation
that i've already found
x equals e
y
what's the x intercept of this equation
x equals e y
what's the x intercept here what are you
okay
it's zero right yeah because you're
putting y equals zero you're going to go
through x equals 0 as well so this
tangent that i would like you all to
draw with me right now it's going to
pass through t
it's also going to pass through the
origin so go ahead pop your ruler in
place
let's see how good your accuracy is
mine's not bad could do it better
there you go
how's that that's my x equals e y
line
i'm actually slightly impressed because
i eyeballed that anyway so there's my
tangent
now you can see here i'm going to use
this as my way to illustrate what is
this next thing we're going to work out
the normal